- So I came in here because they told me
this is a gourmet bacon taste test.
If you're (bleep)ing with me,
I'm gonna be really upset.
(bouncing music)
- Everyone loves bacon.
It's like asking people if
they love, you know, oxygen.
Of course they do. You have to.
- I feel like I'm being ask to
explain why I like chocolate.
'Cause it's delicious.
- Anything with grease
and fat is gonna be good.
- It's good with eggs,
it's good on a sandwich,
it's good with chicken.
- I could live without having bacon,
but it wouldn't be very much fun.
- I never even thought
about a world without bacon.
- Of course I'm excited to have bacon!
We're having bacon in the
morning! What a Tuesday!
- Oh, my God!
- Oh, my gosh, it's a piglet!
- Oh, no! Oh, no.
- Oh, God. Okay. Now I'm never
gonna have bacon ever again.
- It's a tiny little
pig. It's a little pig.
(piglets squeals)
- I mean, he does look
delicious, let's be honest.
- No, watcha doin' now, where ya goin'?
Oh, he's shy! He's a little camera shy!
- I had bacon a few days ago.
Oh, I don't wanna say it too loud.
- What're you thinkin' about?
(piglet squeaks)
- Are my beliefs that fragile that
one little cute thing in my arm
is gonna just change everything I know?
Kinda, yeah.
- Bacon or steak, we look at those things
as pieces of meat on our plate and not
something that wants to
snuggle in your arms.
- How can you wanna eat this little guy?
Look how cute he is!
Look at that face! Look at that face!
- He pooped on me, I take
it back. Eat all the pigs.
I'm just kidding, it's cool.
I gotta say, of all the
animals that pooped on me,
that was probably the most pleasant.